je vous rappelle donc l'information
principale de cette soirée l'équipe
festina a donc été exclu du tour de
france jean marie leblanc le directeur
l'a annoncé peu de temps avant le début
de ce journal ce sont les aveux en fin
d'après-midi de bruno roussel le patron
de l'équipe qui ont donc incité jean
marie leblanc à prendre cette très grave
décision jean marie leblanc que l'on va
écouter des propos qui ont été
recueillis il ya quelques secondes à
peine à l'issue de sa conférence de
presse
après avoir pris connaissance des
derniers éléments
d'information émanant du tribunal de
lille après les avoir longuement pesé
nous avons pris la décision d'exclure
l'équipe festina du tour de france à
compter de ce jour
décision difficile car
nous avons beaucoup pensé aux coureurs
mes décisions qui nous paraissait
indispensable
et que nous espérons salutaire
salutaire et pour le tour de france et
pour le cyclisme et qui nous l'espérons
aussi mettra un terme au climat malsain
qui régnait sur l'épreuve depuis le
départ de dublin